[Music]
it is perhaps the most famous photograph
ever taken it came into being almost by
accident when on the morning of
Christmas Eve 1968 one of the astronauts
aboard the Apollo 8 spacecraft Bill
Anders turned the camera from the
supposed object of their mission the
moon towards a spherical brightly
glowing blue object rising above the
lunar horizon
this was of our irreplaceable planetary
home suddenly humankind was able to view
its habitat with a gaze either too
reserved for the entity we have termed
God it was a moment that invited and
continues to offer us a fundamental
change in perspective although the
theory that the earth was a sphere had
been proposed by ancient Greek thinkers
from Pythagoras onwards such thinking
remained theoretical for hundreds more
years and still remains day to day as we
make our way in the Boris lair and our
streets mountains and seas
largely implausible though the earth
typically appears inexhaustibly vast to
us
suddenly it emerged as what it truly is
just another medium sized planet in one
solar system in one galaxy in a mine's
to finally infinite universe though it
might seem far for an earth dweller to
journey from say New York to Sydney or
from one pole to another these are in
the greater scheme the trails of an ant
Earthrise allowed us to feel a kind of
care even love for the planet viewed
from space we see it protected from
terrific bombardments of meteorites and
solar and cosmic rays and made habitable
only by an infinitesimally thin membrane
which it is now wholly within our powers
to destroy our oxygen-rich atmosphere
that makes the difference between a
barren desert planet like Mars and our
own lush abundant breathable home
appears in the photo as the vaguest of
halos from up here it's possible to feel
so much more generous towards the human
project than we normally do we can smile
gently at humanity and perhaps admire it
a little too everyone's faults drop away
against such Majesty we are tucked
towards being more patient and warm
around our fellow ants spinning with us
in endless darkness we might like to
tell one or two of these ants in franca
more direct terms have fond we are of
them on the planet right now babies are
being born adults are crying themselves
to sleep people are on their knees
hoping for redemption there is struggle
error folly and hope the photograph
urges us toward a higher form of
kindness and forgiveness there is
probably no divine being to look down on
us and help us it's only us responsible
for us
fragile home we may have to adopt for
ourselves some of the attitudes we once
projected on to our divinities if there
were to be a new religion one without a
God a secular religion set up to remind
us of our need to love to be kind and to
forgive then earth rise might fittingly
be its logo and its central image but
even without such a fanciful though
perhaps necessary creation Earthrise
deserves a place maybe on the kitchen
wall or on our screensavers and
definitely in our minds a constant
reminder of our power our vulnerability
and our deep responsibility to one
another
[Music]
the school of life isn't just a YouTube
channel it's an actual school where you
can go and take classes we have branches
in ten locations around the world
to find out more click on the link on
the screen now